eine youtube business e mail adresse ist
für jedermann öffentlich zugänglich
sodass mir einerseits unternehmen
anfragen für kooperationen zu senden
können und auf der anderen seite
zuschauer video vorschläge schicken
das problem daran dass meine
emailadresse öffentliche ist es
allerdings dass wirklich jeder scheiß
vollidioten e mail schicken kann von
daher habe ich mir fürs heutige video
mal gedacht dass ich euch einige male
zeige ich über die letzten monate
gesammelt habe wo ich mir einfach nur an
kopf gefasst habe und mir gedacht habe
beschwerden kann ich mich da
normalerweise eher weniger
die erste mail die wir uns heute
anschauen ist von einer person namens
ludmilla das ist die ludmilla der name
den die ludmilla mit ihrer
e-mail-adresse verbunden hat ist laut
punkt punkt punkt punkt punkt punkt
punkt
jetzt weiß jeder wer du bist ich erwarte
gegenseitigkeit von ihnen das hat sie in
den betreff geschrieben also das ist das
thema der mail
ich wünsche herrn bedienen um sie mehr
einfach mal durch sie bindestrich ein
interessanter mann adressiert meinen
brief sie sind ein interessanter mann
danke und ich beschlossen sie zu
schreiben
scheiße jetzt schreibt mich die ludmilla
ob mein name ist ludmilla mein alter von
32 jahren im dezember wird meine 33 sste
tag der geburt sein was in meiner stadt
sind männer nur an geld und sex ohne
verpflichtung interessiert
viele paare trafen sich auf websites im
internet ich arbeite für einen arztberuf
immer noch unverheiratet und einsamen
das liebe tut mir leid tut mir wirklich
leid sport das ganze leben mit mir
besucher den pool und fitnessraum dies
ist eine kurze geschichte über mich
hoffe auf gegenseitigkeit von ihnen
wo war das eine geschichte
mir nur gesagt wie scheiße dein leben
ist hoffe sie wegen bald mailen sie mir
freundin aus einem anderen land ludmilla
also das hier ist ja die ludmilla ich
würde sagen wir antworten der einfach
mal sehr geehrte ludmilla mein hobby
ebenfalls sport ich auch haben arztberuf
jeder in meiner stadt auch sex interesse
haben wo freund aus an das land laser
luca mal schauen ob die lust mir dass
wir noch antworten wir aber wir schauen
uns mal die nächste mail an die kamen
nämlich von der lieben dame namens julia
das ist ola die veolia hat in den mail
betreff geschrieben ex meine hallo für
dich danke ja meine hallo hier für dich
zurück wie war dein tag e mail fängt auf
jeden fall schon mal sehr viel besser an
als die von ludmilla also sie platzen
nicht gleich mit der tür ins haus und
sagen wie scheiße ich leben sondern sie
fragt mich wie mein tag war also die
biolitec war bisher sehr cool ich finden
eine nachricht auf bekanntschaft
webseite mit deine kontakt
sie hat auf einer bekanntschaft website
angeblich eine nachricht von mir
bekommen
liebe all das kann ich glaube ich nicht
gewesen sein ich wollen dir schreiben du
interessierst dich treffen beziehungen
wieso platzen die denn alle direkt nach
nur einem satz mit der tür ins haus rein
und wollen sich mit mir treffen ist
verständlich eigentlich nicht ich bin
ledig mädchen und suchen nach
beziehungen ich wollen nicht ledig
bleiben mein name unama ich arbeite im
krankenhaus krankenschwester ich
gefallen meine arbeit also erstmal
verstehe ich das jetzt nicht ganz genau
bei der e mail oben steht sie heißt oh
ja und dann schreibt sie aber in dem
text ulan
aber okay meine liebe julia bzw
solana ich finde es auf jeden fall stark
dass du im krankenhaus arbeitet ich
finde es immer schön wenn leute anderen
menschen helfen und vielleicht kann der
auch demnächst jemand helfen dass du
nicht mehr ledig bist ich mag draußen
aktivität konzerte besuchen ich habe
viele lieblingsaktivitäten wir könnten
gemeinsame hobby zuvor finden um
gemeinsam zu dividieren
[Musik]
also ich würde nichts lieber wache also
nachmittag als wird der ja zu dividieren
kanal ich liebe matte
lasst uns starten einander besser kennen
ich werde erfreut zu bekommen
ein mitteilung bald deutsch gelernt bei
oder du hast schreiben mir nur
personalwünsche oh ja danke auf jeden
fall auch für deine nachricht liebe und
beziehungen solana im dir werde ich
natürlich nun auch direkt antworten
julia tag war super du krankenschwester
ich kranken bruder wir füreinander
bestimmt eigentlich las treffen liebe
grüße luca die nächste mail die ich euch
zeigen möchte kommt von der lieben
schnee sana
das ist schnee sana im betreff der male
fand ich sehr verwirrend und zwar steht
dort einfach geist nebel
ich bin also gespannt wo das ganze jetzt
hingeht wie geht es dir dies ist ein
kleiner brief für dich mein name ist
schnell sana also bisher als dieser
anfang der mail an mein lieblings anfang
sage ich mal von den drei male sich
bisher gezeigt habe also sie interviews
yourself sagt sie hat schnell sein
sie fragt mich wie es mir geht also mal
schauen wie es jetzt weitergeht ich bin
gerade in odessa ich habe dein profil im
internet gefunden sie sind sehr an mir
interessiert
sag mal warum
finden diese ganzen leute irgendwelche
profile von mir auf irgendwelchen
webseiten man gibt es interessiert mich
schreibt mir wie alt bist du ich brauche
einen mann und suche einen mann wenn du
mir schreibt wird es gut
ist ja echte absolute wahnsinn
allein die tatsache dass sie so schreibt
ich brauche einen mann und suche einen
mann wenn du mir schreibt wird es gut da
gar nicht mehr schick ich hoffe dass dem
ein foto gefällt ich warte auf deine
antwort leider sehe ich selten die
antworten schnell sana ich warte auf
deine antwort aber sie sieht nur selten
antworten
warum soll ich dann überhaupt antworten
china sein aha warum sollen ich
antworten wenn du sehen selten antworten
und semikolon lg remscheid leute ich bin
auf jeden fall hardcore gespannt ob mir
ludmilla oh ja und cesana noch antworten
werden soll ich eventuell falls hier
antworten werden nochmal euch die mails
anzeigen lassen leichter bei diesem
video schreibt mir und in die kommentare
timo ja oder nein
lief
[Musik]
zum 1